I was in the store the other day and I
literally heard this conversation a
woman was talking to her friend and she
said I just need to get on blank which
was a crowdfunding platform huh and find
all these rich people that want to
donate to these indie films I know
they're there and they're waiting and I
was like wow this is so good and I was
trying to listen to more than they
passed by and I couldn't hear anything
more but I see that idea out there and I
see hashtag support indie film and
that's great but that's a bunch of indie
filmmakers that were there all seeing
that hashtag yeah so who are those
people waiting to donate to these
campaigns are they people that are
interested in a niche that the film is
about if the film is about a group of
women let's say where there's no
relationships no sex but they're all
maybe friends and they're struggling
with their own issues is that the
demographic for that film or is it a
bunch of people that have all this
disposable income that just can't wait
to hashtag support indie film I don't
think there are that many people out
there desperately waiting to throw their
money at indie phone the people of means
who I know who contribute to indie film
do it in a very savvy way as investors
and if you are going to approach an
investor right which is different from
approaching a crowdfunding audience if
you're going to approach an investor
with a plan for success as a reason why
they should give you a bunch of their
disposable income you have to show them
demonstrably that you can make money on
the film the only way that you can ever
demonstrably show that you can make
money on a film is by proving that you
have access to the audience that wants
to see this film if your business plan
says I'm going to go to a big festival
that I haven't gotten into yet and get
picked up by a distributor for whom you
know that who picks up one or two titles
out of festivals a year and that's my
path to access to audience most savvy
independent film investors at this point
are saying give me a break so the whole
conversation has shifted
you can't even I mean sure you could
present that
you know I'm gonna go to a big festival
and I'm gonna get picked up by a big
distributor business plan to people
who've never invested in film before and
you can tell them a lie that you're
gonna make money this way or you can do
the work to build the audience tell them
the truth and make sure that when they
invest in this film they make their
money back so they invest in your next
film like the thing about crowdfunding
and about gathering investment for film
in general is that we all have a
responsibility to one another we have a
responsibility to do successful
crowdfunding campaigns so that everybody
who touches crowdfunding has a great
experience we have a responsibility to
pay our investors back so those
investors will not only invest in our
films but other people's films I think
we're you know too long we have been
like oh I'm just need to hit people in
their pocketbooks no you have to hit
them in their hearts that's that's why
most independent film investors invest
actually even the ones who make money
regularly invest because it really
touches them and moves them and
certainly crowdfunding campaigns are won
and lost by reaching the people who give
a can I say that
sure great crowdfunding campaigns are
won and lost by reaching the people who
give a about what you are talking
about you know they're and they're
segmented right there's the people who
give a that a group of women are
making a movie together right because
they care about women and media there's
a there's the segment of people who feel
like you know women's friendships are
not accurately represented on screen and
that's why they might have contributed
to like the water and then there's the
group of people who are really
interested in you know delving into
stories about grief those are harder
people to reach like this is why raising
money for drama is difficult in the
first place because like getting people
to out themselves about difficult
subject matter can be complicated but
it's not like your audience has one
quality or can be spoken to in one way
or can be reached on a single platform
and that's why it is on you
as the producer or the whatever
filmmaking team you have to know enough
about your audiences and their
proclivities in order to reach them so
there's no platform that's going to do
this work for you because they can't
they fundamentally can't there's no
platform that has the resources to do
all the research that it takes and
fundamentally that audience should
belong to you not just for a single film
but for your next film and the one after
and the one after so for like the water
how did you build that audience because
it was 2011 oh so boy if I knew then
what I know now how I would have done
everything differently we largely for
like the water relied upon the strength
of our personal networks but we had six
women pushing this campaign not on a
crowdfunding site we had six women out
there telling the story about what it
would take us to make this film and why
we deeply wanted to do it and the
fortunate thing is that with six women
we were reaching into six different
cities the seventh and then a seventh
which is New York and an eighth which
was Los Angeles because that's sort of
where our networks were and we were
telling this story really passionately
and really concisely and we knew nothing
about crowdfunding
like we were literally making it up as
we went along but the wish list really
helped us articulate this is not about
you giving us money this is about the
community coming together to sort of
acquire the stuff that it will take to
bring this story to life and what
happened well those people ended up also
being our our extras and as we moved
into the small town where we were
shooting we got a local car dealership
involved and a coffee shop involved and
the fire department involved and the
police department involved and the I
mean all of these community folks sort
of rallied around it because we had a
really clear way to articulate our story
and we took a lot of lessons away from
that and built them into seed and spark
but I can't I can't lie and say this was
foresight right like the things that I'm
telling you now
are all things that I learned by doing
and failing or not failing
along the way I guess not feeling would
be succeeding along the way
you